if all of what you're saying is true
[Music]
why are we being told or everything
we're being told
why does every major european government
and american government and every other
government seemingly in the world
why are they all considering a green new
deal
why are we being told that we need to
desperately urgently invest in renewable
energy
before we all die why why is this all
going on in your opinion
if none of what what i've put to you is
correct
because the key to controlling the
populace is fear and guilt
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis
foster i'm constantine kitchen and this
is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people
our brilliant guest today is the
co-founder of greenpeace
and the director of the co2 coalition in
arlington virginia
patrick moore welcome to trigonometry
great to be with you constantine
and francis we're both here uh it's good
to have you on the show
anne francis hi that's right that's
right don't don't worry about him you
don't really need to talk to him
uh patrick uh but welcome uh it's great
to have you on the show
um we had roger hallam who is the
co-founder of extinction rebellion on
our show
some time ago um and we had a chat
with him about environmentalism and all
of those things so we wanted to bring in
a different perspective which is why
we're delighted to welcome you to the
show
before we get into the conversation
itself tell everybody a little bit about
who are you how are you where you are
what has been the journey that you've
had through life because it's an
interesting one
you know i introduced you as a
co-founder of greenpeace you you did you
were involved with that movement and
then you moved away from it
uh and just tell us a little bit about
how all of that has happened
well i grew up on the very northwest tip
of vancouver island
in a completely remote wilderness area
with no road to it
so i grew up with boats i went to school
by boat
i had a boat when i was six i had a
motor for it when i was 12.
so i had a completely unique uh
childhood
in the wilderness of northern vancouver
island in the rainforest by the pacific
and i learned to love nature at an early
age as a result
so when i was sent away to boarding
school after
the one-room schoolhouse here only went
to grade 8
i had to go to vancouver where i learned
city ways
and went into life science in a big way
biology biochemistry and genetics and by
the time i got to university
i already was well versed in those
subjects and did a bsc
honors in biology and forestry
uh the industry that i grew up in up
here on the north end of vancouver
island where
there are far more trees than people and
anything else you can name
and so uh i then i then
found out about the science of ecology
during a
lunchtime lecture by an expat
czechoslovakian
who had come here to get away from the
communists as he'd been in the
underground against them after the
second world war
and he taught me about ecology and
forest ecology
and uh that was it for me that's what i
decided i wanted to spend my life
studying
that word had not yet been printed in
the public press
environment was being talked about a lot
by the early 1970s
when i joined this small group in a
church basement in vancouver that's
where greenpeace began
to take a voyage across the north
pacific
with 12 other people in a small fishing
boat
against the u.s hydrogen bomb testing in
alaska
we had the temerity at that time
looked like a bunch of hippies but
actually we were all professionals of
one sort or another by that time
uh to take on the world's largest and
most powerful
organization the u.s atomic energy
commission at the time
at the height of the cold war and we won
president nixon partly as a result of
providing a focal point for media
attention
to the nuclear tests we had tens of
thousands of people marching in the
streets as a result of our voyage
being shown on television around the
world and
when that bomb went off we didn't stop
that one
but when it went off people came from
both sides of the u.s canada
border the largest undefended border in
the world to join hands against
nuclear testing and the threat of
nuclear war
and so uh this became
kind of the cusp of the cold war
we were right there at that time we
didn't do it but we sure
put an exclamation mark on it and
when president nixon canceled those
remaining tests it began
the de-escalation of nuclear weapons
buildup
and the talks to reduce nuclear weapons
between the soviet union
as russia was called then and the united
states of america
so and we were just a bunch of canadians
uh
trying to do something useful at that
time in history
so i spent the next 15 years full time
with greenpeace in the top committee i
was a director all the way through
i was the ostensible leader for a couple
of years in
in between there and then when we
created greenpeace international in 1979
to bring together
all the different groups that had sprung
up in australia new zealand france
britain netherlands canada and all over
the united states
we became a quite powerful force going
on
eventually to stop french atmospheric
nuclear testing
in the south pacific the slaughter of 30
000 whales every year
in the world's oceans and then on to
toxic
waste at that time in the late 1970s
pretty well all the rivers in europe and
britain were dead
because of factories putting poison in
through pipes coming in under water
and we created the riverboat
named the beluga a smaller boat than
we'd been using on the high seas
and we took it up the rivers and frogmen
went down and plugged the pipes
of these factories and backed the
effluent up into the factory itself
and just the image of that made really
good media
and uh today the rhine the rhone
the elb the thames have fish in them
and that's very much because of what we
did back then
well as time went on we evolved from a
group of volunteers
into a famous environmental organization
with people throwing money at us
and pretty soon we had a fairly big
payroll with lots of people working
at doing good things and then when you
have a payroll
you have to do fundraising and
fundraising suddenly
over time became maybe more important
than
it should have been and
pretty soon you're a business basically
and
with a payroll to meet and gradually
that sort of took over the importance of
what campaign you were doing
and in the late uh
70s into the early 80s my fellow
directors
there were six of us in greenpeace
international as directors
decided none of whom had any formal
science education as
i did decided greenpeace should take on
a campaign to ban chlorine worldwide
and i'm going like hey you guys that's
one of the elements in the periodic
table you know like
one of the building blocks of the
universe and
probably shouldn't be trying to ban that
just now
maybe a little more subtle approach
would be in order
but in you know that a bit of a joke
there but
uh in fact chlorine is the most
important
element for public health and medicine
adding it to drinking water was
the most important move in public health
in history
and 85 of our medicines are based on
chlorine chemistry
25 of them actually have chlorine in
them
we we ingest it in order to cure
ourselves
so banning it worldwide was not a good
idea i tried to impress them
of that and they went on
any ways to do it so that was sort of
the micro reason why i had to leave
greenpeace as i couldn't be part of an
organization that wanted to ban
the most important element for public
health and medicine but that kind of
reflected on the larger philosophical
issue
by this time many members of the green
movement
were beginning to call people
the enemies of the earth humans are the
enemies of nature
and as if we were the only bad species
on the planet
uh that was just a bit too much like
original sin
for me i'm not a fire and brimstone guy
not even particularly
of a particular religious bent
more of a scientist and uh
i had to leave and i was sorry that had
it had
ended up like that but i'm really glad i
did now because over the years it's
basically turned into a racket peddling
junk science
and doing basically nothing other than
trying to scare people into thinking the
world is coming to an end
and the whole ocean is full of plastic
and it's killing everything
and just a lot of lies it's interesting
because
we wanted to talk to you about the
plastic and the global warming and all
of that stuff and i know you will have a
lot to say on it
but one of the questions you just
brought up yourself is this idea that
humans are
a sort of plague on the planet uh isn't
that
i mean isn't that true patrick like
we're we're consuming all the resources
we're polluting everything
uh people would say the world is
overpopulated
uh we're we're having to modify crops
just to be able to feed the population
we're messing around with all sorts of
things
um you know we're probably going to end
up having to go to mars to try and you
know you know
you get the picture i'm trying to paint
here right isn't all of that true
no that would be a simple answer uh
no it's not true we are perfectly good
species
and most of us uh actually uh try to be
good people and good good species
there's
al always a few bad ones in i guess
whatever species
there's probably bad mice and bad
birds and you know that that don't like
the other birds
or whatever but uh we are
a perfectly fine species we do
a lot especially since the
era of mechanization ended up
causing pollution because we were
burning fuels without any control
we have done a lot to mitigate that and
i mean if you were where i am today on
the north end of vancouver island you
were
you would not think there's too many
people and one of the reasons people
think there's too many people
is because most of them are crowded into
dense urban
centers which occupy about two percent
of the land on this earth
and the land is only 25 of the surface
of the earth
so it's way less than one percent of the
planet
that is covered in concrete full of
people
and those people in that concrete
don't have a very good balanced
understanding
of what the whole earth actually looks
like
if they would go they should fly more
over top of
the countryside where they live even
europe which is one of the densest
populations if you fly over it you see
nothing but
trees you know you see the odd city here
and there when you land and when you
take off
but europe is 43
forested the eu the entire eu
has 43 forest cover 250 years ago
it was less than 10 percent because
wood was being used as the energy source
for
everything and for building
of course as it still is today but in
those days
uh the forests were disappearing in
europe and
that caused humans to invent the science
of silviculture
often referred to as forestry uh they
like to call it deforestation
uh but if you plant trees after you cut
the ones that are growing there in the
first place
it is called reforestation not
deforestation and europe has become very
good
at reforestation in fact getting right
into it the meat and potatoes of it
china and india are doing more
to help green the earth than any other
countries
because they are so populated because
there are so many
people and they are emitting so much co2
about as much between the two of them as
the whole rest of the world combined
they are fertilizing the earth with
carbon dioxide which is causing the
trees
and food crops to grow 30 to 40 percent
faster than they were
just 50 years ago and because they have
so many people
they need a lot of food and they need a
lot of wood so they are planting vast
areas of forest
in once denuded areas before they
started thinking about what they should
really be doing
which is planting more trees and china
and india between the two of them
are responsible more for the greening of
the earth than
any other countries and are producing
more biomass
more living material in the form of
photosynthetic
plants like trees and food and all the
wild plants too
uh and are actually doing a great
service
to the to the planet uh and that's the
that is the irony and why i am a member
of the co2 coalition
because they've got it completely
backwards carbon dioxide
is not some kind of toxic poison brought
by martians to kill everybody
carbon dioxide is the food of life
it is what plants eat and we have to
start thinking like a plant
because we're not a plant we're an
animal that eats plants
and if it wasn't for the plants we
wouldn't be here
animals could never have existed if it
weren't for the fact that plants
came first they came first
and made the oxygen because they
consumed carbon dioxide
kept the carbon for themselves to build
wood
and fibers and fruits and vegetables
and then they gave off the oxygen
in to the atmosphere which made it
possible for animals to evolve in the
first place
so we owe our entire existence to plants
and should therefore worship them
regularly
and make sure we understand just exactly
what the formula
is on this planet instead of thinking
that by burning fossil fuels
which are in fact made from plants do
people understand this
come on people plants made the fossil
fuels
fossil fuels were made by solar energy
in the forests and in the grasslands of
this earth
and they got buried those forests got
buried and
turned into hydrocarbons they started
out as carbohydrates
all they did was lose their oxygen and
became
hydrocarbons like coal and oil and gas
and we are now releasing that solar
energy that they captured
so hydrocarbons fossil fuels
are the greatest storage battery of
solar energy on this earth and we should
use them
judiciously which is why i favor nuclear
energy
because it could actually supplant a
great deal of fossil fuels
in an effective way unlike wind and
solar which don't work
three quarters of the time they could
actually work all the time as they do
there's 440 nuclear plants operating
in around the world today nearly 100 of
them are in the united states
and no citizen of the u.s has ever been
harmed
by a nuclear plant and i don't believe
any citizen of the uk
or if the eu has ever been well
charitable did
affect the eu of course and it was the
only nuclear accident in the history of
nuclear energy that killed people
and it was about 86 people according to
the world health organization
greenpeace says it was 300 000 who died
in chernobyl
but they don't have gravestones or names
so i suspect something is amiss there in
their calculation
so patrick before we touch on nuclear
power
there i there is a narrative that is
being spread at the moment by people
like extinction rebellion you know greta
thomberg
and so on and so forth that our planet
is in grave danger we have something
like 50
you know harvest left if we don't do
something now
we're facing a climate catastrophe are
the words that they use
is this accurate and what is and if it's
not
what is the reality of the situation
that we face because global warming is a
thing isn't it
yes and we're in a climate emergency
right now can't you see outside
the climate emergency which is unfolding
about you
it's complete hogwash there is no
climate emergency obviously
this is a prediction that they are
making for the future
very near in the future apparently but
it isn't here
yet because even the ipcc the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change of the united nations
which is controlled by china apparently
even the ipcc
cannot hide the fact that there is no
increase in any extreme weather event
occurring since weather events began to
be recorded
which is quite a while ago nothing is
unusual about what is happening in the
weather today
in this world nothing so this cannot
possibly be called a climate emergency
if every country can
we're talking about rising sea levels
you know the you know the
the the ice is melting in the arctic
all of these don't forget the polar
bears yeah and let's let's talk about
the polar bears as well you know
surely isn't that some let's talk about
the polar bears
that's a good idea the polar bear
owes its very existence to climate
change
there would not be any polar bears if it
wasn't for climate change
the climate change i'm referring to is
not the weather it is the reduction in
global temperature
that has occurred over the last 50
million years we are at the tail end of
a 50 million year cooling period on this
earth
the graphs are there to see the data is
there to see it's from marine sediment
analysis
showing that the eocene thermal maximum
it's even got a name peaked 50 million
years ago
and since then the earth has cooled
to where we are today how many people
actually know that we are in the place
to see an
ice age today this is the place to see
an ice age
we are in an interglacial period
one of about 40 to 45 we don't know
exactly
because it goes back 2.6 million years
which is when the people who are in
charge of figuring out when to name an
age
and then the next stage and the next one
after that
they say we are in the place to see an
ice age today
and that this is the holocene
interglacial period
which is a slight warming from when
ice covers a very large part of the
entire northern hemisphere
like all of canada for example right
down
into the northern united states 20 000
years ago that's the picture
of the earth an ice sheet
miles thick covering the whole of canada
and down into the u.s
that ice sheet melted over the last 20
well for
for 10 000 years after that and for the
last 10 000 years
we have been in what's called an
interglacial period which is still
colder note there are large sheets of
ice on both poles
for the 250 million years before that
there was no ice on the north pole
none because it was warmer
for 250 million years before that
so those are the kind of time periods
that people have to consider
when talking about the climate of the
earth and it's conducive
to life or not it was very conducive to
life when the whole earth was warmer
than it is today
because life then existed where there is
ice today
but let's get back to the polar bears
depending
on i'm sorry to interrupt again but
before we get back to the polar bears
which i'm really keen to do
i i really appreciate you setting this
in the historical context which i think
is essential if you're
going to discuss this but there is a
flaw in what you're saying isn't there
which is
the argument about the changing climate
is that
yes the earth had its cooling and
warming periods for
for millions and millions of years
before but what has happened in the last
200 years with the industrial revolution
is human beings have started to affect
the climate in ways that are not natural
for our planet
and if we mess with it there's a runaway
phenomenon where you simply don't ever
get to go back to
to the normal way of of the planet being
isn't that true
uh no you simply can never go back
run away effect why hasn't that happened
before
and people say well humans weren't here
when it was warmer
yes but our ancestors were every single
living thing on this planet today
every insect every bird every human
represents a continuous successful
reproduction since the beginning of life
we are the toughest baddest ass species
that ever existed because we have lasted
longer
than any other species all the species
that are on earth today
have come through the gamut of cold and
heat
and whatever nature through at us
we are still here and it isn't as if we
just
popped up out of the ground we came
from reproduction over
millennia from you know any any time
people get together and don't have
children that line
ends that's the pruning of the
evolutionary bush
and it's been going on since the
beginning of life
so no there's what we what we have done
is caused slightly more than one degree
celsius
increase in global temperature if you
believe
the people who are trying to tell us
we're all going to die if we don't stop
putting co2 into the atmosphere
they are manipulating these numbers all
the time
the sea level rise 2 000 years ago
the sea level in britain was
much higher than it is today there's
remains of roman docks
in the south of england that are way
inland
that's right i've been to some i've been
to some patrick it's interesting i've
been to
i think it's pevensy castle uh here in
the south of england
which used to be a a fortress that would
guard the sea
it's now about five or ten miles inland
yes many of the southern towns in
britain
were ports at at that time 2 000 years
ago
so it's gone up and down and up and down
for the last 7
000 years the sea did rise 400 feet
120 meters as the ice sheet melted
from 20 000 to 10 000 years ago
that was sea level rise 400 feet
but what i say today when the sea is
rising
less than an inch per year way less than
an inch per year
on average is you have two choices
if the sea rises to where you don't want
it to be
either move to higher ground that would
be
a fairly logical uh choice to make so
that you were not inundated by the sea
or hire the dutch they have been
very successfully uh protecting
25 of holland is below sea level
and you could do that with manhattan for
example because
there's a lot of people in
infrastructure there would be worth
building dikes around manhattan
we can build things so fast these days
we can make whole new cities look what
the chinese have done in just the last
30 or 40 years
i mean if you if you set your mind to it
these days with the technology we have
it's no problem so let's forget about
that one
for a bit can i go back to polar bears
yeah
yes you can because i like them as well
actually
they actually highlight a lot of
important principles
as i said if it weren't for climate
change there'd be no polar bears
i'm going to try to get that through uh
extinction rebellion's thick head
uh so before there were polar bears when
the earth was warmer
there were only brown bears the eurasian
brown bear as it is called i'm sure you
know what i mean
over here we call them grizzly bears but
they are the same species because
the grizzly bear came to the new world
at the same time people did
15 000 years ago or so when the sea
was 400 feet lower bearings
land bridge occurred between russia and
alaska
so along came the humans
the brown bear which we call grizzly
bear
the moose which in swedish is lk
uh so they sort of call it an elk but we
have another kind of elk over here that
was here already
and uh the caribou which you call
reindeer they came them too and so did
the timberwolf
so those five species of mammals weren't
even in the new world
until 15 000 years ago so then the world
started to cool and the
eurasian brown bear hived off
as the arctic began to freeze and ice
sheets formed
and seals under the ice could be hunted
by a bear the
the eurasian brown bears split
into two populations one population went
to the arctic
to hunt seals under the ice at that time
they were still brown and they were
still eurasian brown bears but they
gradually evolved into a white bear for
camouflage
and developed a diet that was much more
carnivorous because there aren't many
plants
in the arctic like there are where the
brown bear lives
so the polar bear is actually
the offshoot genetically of the eurasian
brown bear
and today because they're not separated
by much
time only a few hundred thousand years
because of that they can still breed
successfully between the two
they seldom find each other because
one's in the arctic and ones
on the land down south but if they are
put together
they can produce viable offspring
which is actually the definition of a
species but we
see the polar bear as being so distinct
from the brown bear
that we give it a separate species name
there you go if it wasn't for the
descent into the pleistocene ice age
that began three or four million years
ago and
was finally said to be this is now an
ice age
2.6 million years ago that caused the
eurasian brown bear to evolve
into a polar bear and that's why they
wouldn't exist if it weren't for climate
change now as to their population
and the threat of extinction and all of
that
here's the true story in the early 70s
wildlife biologists went to the leaders
of the polar countries which is russia
canada the united states
norway and denmark of all places because
it owns greenland which actually has
quite a lot of polar bears on it and
told them
that that the hunting of polar bears
had increased to such a level that is a
threat to the population
they had been reduced to somewhere
between six and ten thousand individuals
at that time so all the polar countries
came together and signed an
international treaty in 1973
to end the unrestricted hunting of polar
bears
how many members of the public are aware
of that
none of them are told this the media
never talks about the international
treaty
to end the unrestricted hunting of polar
bears because by
the early 70s it'd become real easy to
take a plane to the arctic hire an inuit
guide
and get yourself two or three polar bear
rugs for in front of your fireplace
and lots of people had enough money to
do that and it was a thing to do
so the polar bears were diminishing
since that treaty was signed the polar
bear population
has grown to somewhere between 30 and 50
000
it's not easy to count them all because
they're distributed all around the north
pole on the ice pack
and that's one of the reasons they can
make up this fake story
that's why my book is called fake
invisible catastrophes and threats of
doom
because the polar bears might as well be
invisible to nearly everybody on earth
same with coral reefs so they're not
invisible in the sense that if you could
get there and see them and count them
and look at them all
you you could verify them you could see
them
but most people can't see the great
barrier reef or the polar bears
and those have become the two iconic
symbols
of the death of the planet when in fact
they are both
healthier than ever sir patrick
you know that is something as well that
i've been told do you know that the
great barrier reef is dead where once it
was
you know pink coral now it's bleach
white etc etc
i thought is it is that true because
if it's not it's completely recovered
from the bleaching of 2016
which itself was completely exaggerated
and when coral bleaches it is not dead
they don't tell you that you you look at
the headlines from that time
it said 93 of the of the great barrier
reef
is dying they didn't say it was dead
they said it was dying and the
newspapers translated that as dead
they said that it was about to die they
said it was
terminal forbes even said that it was in
its final terminal stage
as if there are previous terminal stages
to the final one
it was just a bunch of hype and the fact
of the matter is peter ridd dr peter
ridd who was fired from
james cook university for daring to
counter
the propaganda from his own fellow
scientists in australia
who are exaggerating the threat to the
reef in order to get
hundreds of millions of dollars in
research money
now how on earth can hundreds of
millions of dollars save the coral reef
what are they going to do they're going
to go out there and
look at it and take photographs of it
and
and dive on it how does that
fix the reef if indeed it was in trouble
they are not coral reef doctors
they are charlatans sucking money out of
the taxpayers
on the pretense that the coral reef is
dying
the main threat to coral reefs is
cyclones which
we call hurricanes that
is what causes real damage to coral
reefs because they're right out there in
the middle of
the ocean with no protection whatsoever
except for their own selves
and very often there's large damage
caused
now bleaching is a really i mean it's a
complicated phenomenon
the coral is a symbiotic union
of an animal and a plant
and do you want me to go on from there
and describe the whole life history of
corals probably not
but probably not when they bleach when
they bleach they're ejecting the plant
the coral animal which is a relative of
jellyfish
is transparent as you you know most a
lot of jellyfish are
basically transparent you can see
through them
that's a true of the coral reef polyp as
it's called
and when they bleach they are ejecting
the plankton
which are the plants in the coral and
again read two pages of my book and you
will understand this
but uh that's that's what happens is
it's just a stage in the life cycle of
the coral to eject these plankton and
then eventually take up new ones
they do it when the ocean gets hot
quickly and they do it when the ocean
gets cold quickly
so it's not just the heating but the
truth is
the great barrier reef is not in the
hottest waters in the world
for coral reefs the most biodiverse
coral reefs are in the coral triangle in
indonesia
which my wife and i have dived on two
occasions
on 10 to 14 day trips so we know
the coral reef very well the coral
triangle reefs very well
they are the most biodiverse in the
world and they are in the warmest oceans
in the world
when the world cooled into the place to
see an ice age
the the range of corals was drastically
restricted from what it had been
during a warmer earth and is now
kind of a sanctuary in the indonesian
ocean which is an archipelago with a
shallow sea and no cold water ever comes
there
so corals do better there than they do
anywhere else in the world there are 600
species of corals there
two-thirds of all coral species and more
reef fish species there than anywhere
else in the world this is also
thoroughly documented in my book which
by the way is titled fake invisible
catastrophes and threats of doom
available on amazon.com
patrick let me let me take a a step back
here and look you've got to understand
we're asking you these questions because
that is what a lot of people think and
that's what a lot of
people are being told so the ignorance
that we show probably from your
perspective is
is because we we have faith that other
people out there are equally as ignorant
as us
so in that very much in that spirit let
me ask you a broader question which is
based on what you've said so far and
your book
the the change in global temperature is
not significant
polar bell is thriving uh you know all
of the other stuff i listed before
not true you also mentioned plastic i
don't want to go to 10 rounds with you
on it i mean people say
the great pacific vortex is the biggest
man-made
object ever which is just a bunch of
plastic rubbish floating in the pacific
etc no it's not there actually is no
such thing as the great pacific garbage
patch it is
a fake thing and again it's because no
one can see it you can't stand on the
beach in california and see
the great pacific garbage patch
because they say it's in the middle of
the pacific ocean far
from land right look at my book there's
a photograph
in it which proves that there is no
great pacific garbage patch
it is totally fake they show a picture
on the internet with underneath it it
says part of the great pacific garbage
patch
and it's this huge patch of debris with
a diver
coming up holding some stuff but in the
background there are mountains
and i looked at that and i thought now
just a minute there are no mountains in
the middle of the pacific ocean
so where was this picture taken ah
the tsunami in japan caused by the
earthquake
that caused the fukushima nuclear crisis
that's where that picture was taken it
is not the pacific garbage patch
it is whole towns that were washed into
the sea
when 20 000 people died from that
tsunami
so they show that that's the only real
picture they show
otherwise if you go to the internet
after googling great pacific garbage
patch
you find photoshopped mock-ups
where people have painted a blob on the
pacific ocean and put an arrow to it
saying great pacific garbage patch
it's totally fake there is no such thing
okay well you're making my point
for me which is all of these things that
i've given to you
you've dismissed which is fair enough so
this is this is
really perfect i proved it
yeah i'm not i'm not disagreeing with
you just to be clear i'm trying to set
up the real question which is
if all of what you're saying is true
why are we being told or everything
we're being told
why does every major european government
and american government and every other
government seemingly in the world
why are they all considering a green new
deal
why are we being told that we need to
desperately urgently invest in renewable
energy
before we all die why why is this all
going on in your opinion
if none of what what i've put to you is
correct
because the key to controlling the
populace is fear and guilt
the combination of which uh is very
effective
like you're driving down the street in
your suv and you think you're killing
your grandchildren
that's what you've been told and that
makes you feel guilty
so you send a big check to greenpeace
thinking they might do something
to stop this from happening which is
garbage to start with because they're
just hobnobbing with the rest of the
crowd at devos
in the world economic forum and
supporting global government which
i think amounts to bureaucrats in
beijing
unelected bureaucrats in beijing and so
the whole
thing is based on fear now let's go back
in history not so far as i did
previously not millions of years
but just thousands of years since people
have been standing on street corners
with signs saying the
end is near and predicting apocalypse
end times cataclysm
and all the rest how many of those
predictions have come
true that the earth is coming to an end
i'd say they're baton zero on that one
seeing as though if the earth had come
to an end we wouldn't be talking with
each other right now
so the earth has never come to an end
despite
hundreds of predictions through the ages
that it was
very soon coming to an end
and anyways what does the end of the
world look like does it implode
explode do the seas catch fire and then
burn the whole land off and everything
is dead
i'm not sure what the end of the world
might look like
but i'm quite sure it has never happened
and therefore is unlikely to happen
anytime soon
especially due to carbon dioxide
emissions
from burning fossil fuels that were made
by solar energy
millions of years ago that we are now
taking advantage of
because we're smart imagine
rabbits finding coal
what would they do with it they would
not have a clue what to do with it and
we actually are
a a pretty special species actually
look at what we've done you have art on
the wall behind you there
how many other species produce art so
prolifically
as the human species does or all the
other things
we do and the idea that we are evil
is at the root of all this
that the enterprise of the human species
predicts the end of the world
that it's just going to happen
automatically because of how awful we
are
is a complete and utter lie
there is no possibility that the world
will come to an end
anytime soon from anything we are doing
as a matter of fact what we are doing
the main effect of our use of fossil
fuels
other than providing 82 or three or four
whatever it is percent
of all the energy we use to stay alive
each day and to get from one place to
another each day
to in other words carry out our
existence
every day the other most important thing
that co2 is doing that fossil fuels are
doing
is greening the earth all you have to do
is go to nassau
greening the earth on the internet and
you will see
the satellite photos the this was
actually pioneered by the commonwealth
science and industry research
organization csiro in australia which is
their peak science body
and they figured this out in the mid
2000s or i think it was 2014
actually when they publish their map
showing
up to 30 increase in vegetation
growth especially in the driest parts of
the world
because co2 increased co2
not only results in faster plant growth
because that's the food for plants co2
also
makes plants more water efficient
in other words more drought resistant
because when there's more co2 it's
easier for the plants to
to take it in so they don't make as many
holes under their leaves which is where
they take it in
and that means less water escapes from
them so they can survive on a smaller
amount of
water than they could when co2 was lower
so co2 is performing miracles
with the life on earth and making our
you know why are there record food crops
every year
the main reason is increased co2
that is the primary reason and people
are not being told that
they're being told a pack of lies about
co2 like as if it's bad
when in fact nobody can
question that it is the main food for
life
it is the main food for plants and it is
the main food for animals because
animals eat plants that is their food
and
plants are made from carbon from co2
so therefore so are we yeah
i take your point so then why is it that
over the last couple of years
you know we we've you know these we've
been fed this narrative we've had greta
thundberg
on the tv all over the news and media
saying you know that the planet is
ending is it is it really
to instill people with fear because what
you're saying
is very orwellian if i'm being honest if
there is
evil in this world it's this movement
to try to convince people that they
should commit mass suicide
by ending the use of fossil fuels
there's people living
on the 30th floor of a condominium
in 500 cities
of over a million people
they sleep at night while the trucks
bring the food in from the countryside
big trucks that are not going to be
running on batteries anytime soon
the food that those trucks are carrying
was produced with the help of very large
tractors and combines and other
mechanization
that make it possible for less than five
percent of the population
to grow all the food for the rest of the
people
who are living in the cities where there
isn't any room to grow the food
not on a balcony on the 30th floor of a
condominium
if you're lucky enough to have a balcony
so they don't see the
trucks coming in to resupply the stores
every night with food
they don't even have a clue where their
food is coming from
they don't understand a thing about it
this
is the downside of mechanization
mechanization has been a
wonderful thing to take the burden of
labor
manual labor off a huge percentage
of the population at one time it took 80
percent of the people to grow the food
and the other 20 percent lived with the
other lords and ladies in the castle
with the king
but the uh the 80 of them were out
slaving every day
living in hovels so that kids by six and
eight
had to become labor and didn't get
educated because
they were necessary to do part of the
food production
by hand everything by hand
today eighty percent of the people plus
live in
cities and it takes only a small much
smaller proportion of the people
to provide everything the people in the
cities need to survive
the energy the food
and the materials like concrete and
steel
for example and wood to build their
homes
people in the cities think the people in
the country
who are digging and plowing
and cutting and drilling and all the
excavating
and building huge mines that they are
the enemies of the earth
they are the ones who are destroying the
planet
they forget that the only reason those
people are doing that
is so that they can remain alive
in their hives in the city
that's the only reason those people are
doing that well they take a little bit
for themselves along the way
but not as much as most of the wealth is
in the cities
most the people in the cities have more
fancy cars and
travel more and all the rest they got
more money
so patrick someone who's not familiar
with your work who hasn't heard you say
these things before
might be going what kind of
environmentalist is this guy he doesn't
sound green at all to me
uh what what is what are the things that
people who do care about
the environment ecology uh you know
biodiversity etc if those things are
important what should we actually
be doing should we be recycling plastic
and tins and whatever should we be
avoiding taking unnecessary trips should
we be
cutting down our energy consumption what
else should we be doing is first of all
we'll get to the
nuclear power and other stuff in a
second but as individuals
what should people be doing from your
point of view
you mentioned unnecessary trips
um no trip is necessary with
the technology we have today so what
you're basically saying is people can't
go on holidays
because they are really unnecessary um
but i would argue that's not the case
that holidays
uh are a break from whatever you're
doing
in your normal life and the definition
of necessary comes
into question there uh it's not
a hard and fast word um what we should
be doing is making sure the water in the
air and the earth are clean
and not polluted but
they've they have twisted the meaning of
so many words
that they call a carbon dioxide
pollution you know i used to laugh at
people who said their plants liked it
when they talked to them
as if like plants have ears or something
and could listen to music or whatever
but i don't laugh anymore because
i hadn't realized at the time that when
you talk to your plants especially if
you're
standing close to them or sitting close
to them which you normally would be
if you were talking to them you are
breathing out
40 000 parts per million carbon dioxide
which is 100 times the level it is in
the natural air
therefore you are basically breathing
super saturated fertilizer on the plant
and that's why it grows better when you
talk to it
it's a perfectly simple matter and so
they have now in the united states for
example the environmental protection
agency
ruled under obama that carbon dioxide
is a pollutant an air pollutant when in
fact it is the main food for all life
and has no toxic properties whatsoever
so it's not toxic it is the main food
for life
and it is being called pollution the
same thing is true with plastic
they tell me that plastic is leaching
toxins
into the sea that when fish
ingest plastic and when birds ingest
plastic it's leaching toxins into their
body
is that why we wrap most of our food in
plastic
because it's toxic uh the disconnect
here is unfathomably
insane the reason we use plastic
to contain our food is because
it's non-toxic because it is sterile
and the reason adult
albatross feed bits of plastic to their
chicks they're not actually
feeding it to them are causing them to
ingest it
because they're not eating the plastic
they can't digest the plastic
the bits of plastic that the adult
albatross
give to their chicks and indeed continue
the adults continue to
ingest plastic all their lives along
with other hard bits
that they can find in the ocean there's
no pebbles in the sea
they don't float very well so whereas
land
birds use pebbles as a digestive
aid in their gizzard which is a second
stomach that all birds have
birds don't have teeth therefore they
can't chew their food and have to
swallow it whole
sometimes they swallow a whole squid for
example
in order to digest that whole squid
they send it to their gizzard where um
it's a muscular organ where they also
put hard objects of a suitable size
and shape so that the birds can use them
to help grind the food
it's a it's used in industry all the
time for grinding things by putting hard
objects in
the grinder to help grind it birds
figured that out millions of years ago
sir david attenborough your lovely sir
david attenborough
lies and says the birds are mistaking
plastic for food and feeding it to their
chicks
no they're not they are not mistaking it
for anything
they are using it as a substitute
for bits of pumice hard nuts pieces of
wood
and the squid beaks remain in the
gizzard at when the
bird digests the flesh of the
squid because the squid beaks are a hard
object so they
keep them there and those objects all
wear out over time and have to be
replaced
that's why they have to continue eating
ingesting
these digestive aids all their life one
would think that sir david attenborough
having written the secret life of birds
a large book and having done a 10-part
bbc series
on birds that he might know they have
a gizzard he never mentions the gizzard
he never tells the truth
about the hard plastic bits that are
being used as
digestive aids in the chicks gizzard and
in their own gizzard
he pretends that they are mistaking it
for food
and holds up a clear plastic bag on
television
saying that they're ingesting this
thinking it's food they never show a
clear plastic bag being fed to an
albatross chick
because that's not going to happen then
you go on the internet
and if you google plastic in
baby albatross chicks you will find
baby albatross chicks that are mostly
desiccated and half rotten they've had
their
side cut open and they've been stuffed
with plastic objects they are
staged uh artifacts
they do this in order to make people
think
that birds are stupid when in fact birds
are not stupid they are very intelligent
and they don't feed their chicks things
that they mistake for food they know
what
food is just like we do and we don't eat
plastic bags or bits of hard plastic
because we don't have a gizzard
like birds do and there's also the great
walrus suicide pact
where the walruses are filmed by
sir david attenborough leaping from a
cliff
to their death he says it's because
there isn't enough ice in the arctic
that's why they commit suicide
because they're too crowded on the land
and actually they don't belong on the
land
they belong on the ice well there must
be some reason that this area of land on
the northern russian coast
is called a walrus sanctuary like it's
designated as a walrus sanctuary
so walrus must go on it occasionally
as a matter of fact that's where they go
when the ice recedes in the summer north
from the northern russian coast it
happens every year
so there is no ice to get on
during the summer turns out the reason
the walruses leapt to their death
was because a pack of 20 to 30 polar
bears was coming up from behind them
and they were at the top of a cliff they
just happened to have gone up
walked up waddled up to where they were
at the top of a cliff and they were
trapped
because this group of polar bears came
but sir david attenborough didn't show
that
he said that the walruses home
is on the ice no the walruses home is in
the ocean
and on the land and on the ice when they
want to get out and rest
but unlike the polar bear whose home is
on the ice in the winter hunting seals
walruses do not hunt seals through the
ice
they are bottom feeders sort of like sir
david attenborough and his film crew of
our planet
walruses use their tusks to harvest
clams from the seabed and other
creatures that live there they cannot
dive more than 300 feet
deep so they have to stay near the shore
they are actually
a shore animal they're a seaside animal
they don't go out into the deep sea ever
because there's nothing there for them
even seals and sea lions can go into
deep water to fish
but walruses don't fish they dig clams
and they have to stay near the beach
they are
a beach beach side species and he just
completely ignores that
gotcha let me drag you back to so we got
to keep the rivers and the air
clean what else should individual people
be doing
to to to be environmentally friendly
protect endangered species
protect endangered species that's a very
important thing to do
you know it wasn't until about a hundred
years ago
that the average person even cared about
endangered species
only a few naturalists and biologists
even knew about what it was and when the
passenger pigeon went extinct
which is one of only two species that
have gone extinct
in north america since european
colonization
people woke up to this because the media
made a deal about it
like passenger pigeons were a mainstay
in markets
all across the eastern united states in
new york they were hanging in groups of
20
outside the shops and then there weren't
any any more
and there had been millions of them so
this dramatic
uh extinction that occurred over a
period of not that many years
with and they were easy to kill they
flew at low elevation in large flocks
and that's what really triggered the
concern for
endangered species in this world and so
it's only been a short time since
anybody even cared about that
i mean before that everybody just
thought well if a species goes extinct
it goes extinct
species have been going extinct forever
way more species have gone extinct than
exist in the world today like
a thousands of times more species
some of the great extinction events
which were the last one we were quite
certain
was caused by an asteroid piercing the
earth's crust and throwing
billions of tons of debris into the
stratosphere where it blocked out the
sun for many years
and basically uh ended the food chain
that it killed all the plants and
therefore there was nothing for the
animals to eat
now interestingly one of the reasons
birds survived
uh through that extinction event so and
they
none of the none of the dinosaurs that
walked
on the earth survived but the ones that
flew
did because they could fly hundreds of
miles
to eat the carrion from the ones that
died so
they survived through that because of
flight and of course today we
realize how important flight is to
animals when you've got so many
different bird species
uh that have survived through the all
these ages
that's just along the side um but but
there's been five great extinctions
of life one thing though
but one thing that i will put what i
will ask you about and i think it's a
final thing
is the amazon and deforestation surely
that is a huge problem
no it's not 90 of the amazon is intact
again it's a situation where not even
many brazilians
ever go to the amazon there's no reason
to go there
it is basically a very hot steaming
jungle
it's been described as a human desert
because there's so few people there
ten percent of the amazon has been
developed
into cattle ranching and other forms of
farming
it is not a sea of factories
spewing smoke it is a huge
wilderness area i have flown across it
it takes five
hours to do so i have been at the mouth
of the amazon i've been at jari part way
up the amazon
i've been at manaus where the rio negro
comes into the amazon
so i've seen a huge part of it
it is still there it is not deforested
and the fires they show you that take up
the entire frame of course
nothing but flames right it doesn't take
a very big
fire to take up the whole lens of a tv
camera
most of those fires are re-clearing land
that is being used for cattle because
the vegetation grows so
fast there that when they built a road
to manaus
it quickly disappeared as plants
came up through the pavement and
destroyed the road
it is an amazing living ecosystem
and they've rekindled
the amazon as dying meme as a result
of the election of a president
who is not a communist
and therefore they're just going after
him
saying that he's destroying the amazon
like they did 20 years ago
and as i say i've been there i've been
all over brazil right from the south to
the northeast to the west
brazil is an amazing country it is
nearly as large as the lower 48 united
states
and amazon is a huge piece of it
which is largely intact
look at a map that shows
the reservations that have been made for
the indigenous people of the amazon
and the national parks in the amazon and
if you
own a piece of land in the amazon you
are only
allowed to develop 20 of it
and the actually brazil even in the
south where the main agriculture is
has some of the best land use practices
in the world
they require that 20 of all
agricultural land private land
be kept in nature and that all
streamside areas be protected
and left in natural vegetation
you take a look in england they farm
right up to the bank of the river
maybe a willow tree finds a footing
there that they can't
you know they leave alone but
brazil actually has really good land use
planning
you've been very critical of the united
kingdom in this you've slated david
attenborough
our farming practices and all the rest
of it
as well you deserve but i'm sure you'll
be happy to find out birds have a second
stomach because you'd love them
yeah i'm just speaking to the home
audience you know
yeah patrick but it's great listen let
me ask you uh we've got a final question
to come but
very very quickly because we're we're
running over in a couple of minutes
talk to us about nuclear energy because
just for context you're talking to
somebody
uh i'm from russia originally my wife
actually was
evacuated from kiev in ukraine
during the chernobyl episode the
disaster that happened there
i i am uh i've never understood why that
one incident which is by the way
caused by human deliberate incompetence
and stupidity
and the uh the the sort of planned
economy of the soviet union and which
then generated human error
why that one incident has been used to
essentially
um you know cause such
resistance to the idea of nuclear power
uh but tell us very quickly your view of
it and whether we should be using
nuclear energy more or less than we are
in the moment
well we are using nuclear energy a lot
at the moment
there are 440 nuclear plants
operating in the world uh
europe actually has uh most of the
countries that have more than
a third of their electricity being
produced by nuclear energy
but the big movement in nuclear today is
in china
india and russia where they are actively
building new plants
right now as we speak and plan many many
more
because they are actually thinking of
the future
nuclear is the energy of the future
because fossil fuels are limited
and one of the most important reasons to
support nuclear energy
is to reduce the rate at which we are
burning the precious fossil fuels
and nuclear can do that more than any
other technology we have today
hydroelectric is wonderful where it is
applicable
but it requires rainfall and topography
to be correct
in order for it to you know you're not
going to have hydroelectricity in saudi
arabia anytime soon
so nuclear is applicable anywhere in the
world you can you can build it anywhere
you want to have energy now chernobyl
was an exceptional situation the
charitable class of reactors
built by the soviets behind the iron
curtain
without any input from western science
and western nuclear
understanding those reactors there were
more than
20 of them spread out over the former
soviet union in
all the satellite countries as well
including slovakia for example
those reactors were basically the same
design
as they were using to make plutonium for
nuclear weapons
and they were a flawed design in that
they had
a positive void co coefficient which
would take too long to explain
as opposed to a negative void
coefficient what that meant was they
were
actually capable of a runaway nuclear
reaction
if things weren't done properly and most
people don't realize that the
chernobyl accident did not come during
normal operating procedures
like making electricity it came when a
group of
when a group of scientists came from
nuclear headquarters probably in moscow
to do an experiment and there was a lack
of proper communication between the
operators
and these high-level guys who came in to
do this experiment
also they told the operator to shut down
the safety system so that the safety
systems
would not interfere with their
experiment and it blew
up three mile island and fukushima were
not
ex nuclear explosions they were meltdown
of the core
due to lack of cooling water after the
reactor was shut down
so chernobyl was an exceptional
situation
it killed people especially the people
fighting the fire which went on for 10
days
they had a 2 000 ton graphite moderator
which is
pure carbon which was very very
difficult to put out and and
indeed it did kill over 80 people
including
the children who died of thyroid uh
cancer which was a small number but they
they were diagnosed too late to save
them
a lot of people did get thyroid
problems but they were diagnosed early
enough that it could be cured
the death rate was not a nice thing
but those are the only people that have
ever died from civilian nuclear reactors
in the world it's not being the case
and and this is a last quarter yeah that
being the case why do we seem to
be so worried about nuclear energy why
do we seem to recall in horror when it's
suggested
as an alternative because it's as fake
it's as fake as the fear of carbon
dioxide it's that fake
there is no reason to be afraid of
nuclear energy
nuclear energy if you if you look at
casualties versus
energy produced nuclear is the safest of
all the electricity producing
technologies and it also takes up less
room
like look how much room wind and solar
takes up it takes up vast swaths
and if they make it ten times as much as
it is now it'll take up
a lot of agricultural land where we grow
our food
that they need flat land for these
things
so that is what should be stopped
patrick i agree with you that that's the
one issue on which i will say that
this is one thing i do know a little bit
about having grown up in the soviet
union my father was a
uh someone who was familiar with these
things uh so i i
that's the one thing i can definitely
say that i know about that we can agree
on
uh but listen uh we we're running out of
time it's been such a pleasure speaking
with you and having
a completely different perspective to
the one that we are uh being given
elsewhere um we've got one more question
for you
which is always what's the one thing
we're not talking about but we really
should be
oh yes the one thing we're not talking
about that we really should be
um i think the fact that
aquaculture which is the growing of
fresh and marine water fish
in a farming context as opposed to
catching wild fish
that aquaculture is the way we will save
the wild fish from being
over exploited and aquaculture is being
attacked on every front by the greens
as if it's poisoning the sea or
something
when in fact it takes the pressure off
the wild fish
wild fish have been overfished now for
at least 30 years they should let the
wild fish
recover in many cases they should reduce
the rate of catch of wild fish in the
ocean
and they should increase the amount of
fish being produced by aquaculture
it produces beautiful product almost all
the shrimp you buy
these days is produced in farms
much of the salmon now of course norway
having led
that effort and now british columbia and
chile
and new zealand have followed in their
footsteps
and are producing beautiful product with
aquaculture and tilapia is another one
that is becoming
very successful because it's easy to
grow
and it's inexpensive so fish
has the best proteins and oils of any
protein food any meat that we can eat so
we should be eating
more fish but we can't eat more fish
based on the wild fish because they have
already
been thoroughly over exploited
and i see britain and france arguing
over who's going to get the fish
and it should be more like
let's not catch quite so many of them
next year and let's share them equitably
somehow
but however you do it let's make sure we
don't catch
too many fish because there's the sea is
only capable of producing so much
and these are wild animals we stopped
basing
our food on land our meat on land on
wild animals ten thousand years ago
practically
because we farm animals on the land and
yet the green movement
seems to be adamantly opposed to farming
fish in the sea
in the lakes and in rivers and that is a
completely
bass backwards uh position they should
be supporting aquaculture
to take the pressure off the wild fish
stocks
gotcha patrick thank you so much for
coming on uh remind everybody where they
can find your work online if they want
to follow up this interview and read
more and find out more before we let you
go
uh please just google me patrick moore
uh
and you'll find all kinds of videos etc
but what i'd really like you to do is to
read my new book
fake invisible catastrophes and threats
of doom
it's the result of more than 50 years of
learning on
my part i've been a lifelong learner all
my life
of course and uh please do
read my book it will change the way you
see the world
and in a positive way we should not be
believing in the doomsday narrative we
should believing in the promise of this
earth
and of life upon it thank you and we
haven't had a lot of jokes
i thought you i thought you guys were
comedians well now we're getting scalded
as well yeah
i tried to do a joke at the end there by
saying how dare you
but the internet got in the way how dare
you yeah
yeah patrick listen it's been a pleasure
we're going to do a couple of quick
questions for our supporters as a
separate thing very quickly
and then we'll let you go thank you so
much for watching thank you guys for
watching at home
we will see you very soon with another
brilliant interview like this one
or a raw show all of them go out at 7 00
p.m uk time
take care see you soon guys we hope
you've enjoyed this
incredible interview remember to
subscribe and hit the bell button
so that you never miss another fantastic
episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using
the link below